hopefully here's how you found out what
gundaga's name means in english you'd go
to the api's explorer and search or
scroll to the translate api you list the
translate api functions
and choose
language.translations.list
enter the text to translate which in
this case is gondega
and enter the target language in this
case en
and then you press the execute button
and here's the response from that
execution
see the request but more importantly the
response we see that the translated text
is buttercup what a lovely name
and the detective source language is lv
which is latvia
let me check if that's correct
gondaga where are you from
that is correct i am indeed from latvia